so one of the reasons that religion is
always cited as being so important as
its role in development and on this map
of the importance of religion it's clear
that it's very important in developing
areas but as a management student and
having taken professor Vedas class last
year thick religion only go so far in
developing these countries and I think
at some point there's going to have to
be government and business and and other
sectors involved in raising the wealth
of these countries to raise the standard
of living and robert putnam in his vocal
in the loan would say that the
communities of faith could be training
people to to lay the groundwork of civil
society the rule of law so that
businesses can thrive so the government
can thrive and yet we have this very
solid separation of church and state
that we are you know we encourage around
the world and so I wonder what you see
as do you see religion it's as promoting
development on its own and then you know
there's gonna be sort of different path
of development in these areas or is
there some role for religion to play in
promoting the rule of law being involved
in laying the groundwork of governance
and business yeah I absolutely do think
there is a rip of that role for the
region and and I don't actually think it
depends on the separation of church and
state I mean I may be wrong on this but
it's but this is just my basic feeling
because in Britain we have an
established church which is the Church
of England alright so the Emperor of
which the queen is the head to be
absolute Frank at a day-to-day level it
really it's really a material and I
think the issue is not what is the
constitutional position separate or not
the issue is how far a is government
prepared to allow people of faith into
the business of helping develop society
and be it just as important how
interested are the people of faith in
how their society develops and
developing a rule-based you no
compassion based welfare based system
and and and I think that you know the
very conference we had yesterday which
was about
faith-based organizations and
development showed both their strengths
and their weaknesses but the faith
communities in many of these countries
are the only infrastructure that are
going to be there and they're going to
stay there and so how they develop is
very very important and this is why I
think this is so important about how
that how we view faith if people of
faith have that strong faith that is
grounded in their values right so it's
not just a matter of tradition or
identity it's actually about their
values then I think they are more likely
is my the way I would put it to be
prepared to engage in the way that civic
society develops and in some of those
developing countries they needed but we
also needed here to be absolutely honest
to me if you look at I mean I learned
this in government in in a western
government by the end of it we were
actually trying to bring the faith
communities in because sometimes when we
were dealing with problems to do say
with drugs or rehabilitation of
offenders or HIV AIDS or whatever it was
actually we the religious communities
the faith communities were an important
part of the solution even in countries
like ours but it requires for those
faith communities a certain attitude of
mind I think